hey
it's kristin from ap you look amazing um
oh so jason was talking about how
nervous he was when you were coming down
you know so tell me a little bit about
coming down you know and this is like a
very vegas sort of entrance i feel like
you know well this is my second it's my
home away from home with our residency
not too far from here um so i feel like
i've i've gotten a taste for um vegas
showmanship and it's just so much fun
and we were trying to think of um you
know ways to make this performance um
fresh and fun and like what else can we
do and the song has been such a huge
success and
we love it so much we really just wanted
to take the moment to celebrate it
and when somebody said how would she
feel about descending from
the ceiling i was like i feel good about
that
i was i was excited and it's something
i've never done before and
i'm always up for trying new things i'm
adding a bit of danger into the
performance
hey carrie john katz lamedes with the
review journal here in las vegas i saw
you open at the theater resorts world
and it was great it was really great um
and i wanted i've been wondering how you
felt about falling into the position of
opening that theater originally it was
going to be celine dion's assignment
to come and we know what happened with
her and that fell to you to open it um
how that felt and how you feel generally
about about the residency right now well
i mean first it was definitely you know
concern for celine and wanting her to be
better asap um and then it was like okay
i guess i guess we're up we're up to bat
one thing that we knew about celine is
she's obviously
been here for a while and is such
an amazing performer and professional
and we knew that her opening the theater
they would have everything like all the
loosens tied up by the time we got in um
so then that you know didn't happen i
was like i guess it's up to us you know
and we've never done anything quite like
this before um but everybody really you
know stepped up to the plate and
made it happen and made everybody feel
very confident and wonderful about
opening um and then actually being able
to get out there and do the shows was
just
it
squashed any nerves i could have ever
had about opening it because it was just
so much fun and the crowds were so
amazing and um
we just put together a show that i'm so
incredib incredibly proud of
and can't wait to do more of
congratulations thank you
all right character to head over to our
virtual press room uh first question is
going to be from buddy ian from the
music universe
hi carrie we were actually at your
opening in vegas in december and it was
awesome can we expect a new album and
tour from you this year
um i mean i'm always i'm always working
on on something um obviously we can't
spill too many beans right now but um
uh my fans know what i mean when i say
um soon
soon
[Laughter]
they actually they actually hate it when
i use that word because they're like
what does that mean but um no it's been
been busy for sure
fair enough
thank you buddy we've got a question
from christina boss from nash news
hi carrie congratulations
um i just want to talk a little bit
about having a female finally win
entertainer of the year i know you're
probably so happy for miranda we're
happy for her too so what does that feel
like to finally have a female in that
spot well i i did win um not too long
ago but
it is always wonderful when um there are
so many incredibly talented women in
this genre and
miranda's long overdue
for winning this award um so i couldn't
be more proud of her as a sister in
this genre of music in this industry um
so yeah i mean there were a lot of
incredible females on stage tonight and
i look forward to more of that happening